o hijos de inmigrantes.
Cada uno de nosotros tenía un sueño cuando venimos aquí,
un sueño que, por lo general, debe ser reescrito
y siempre reeditado.
Yo fui uno de los afortunados.
La revisión de mi sueño me llevó al trabajo que hago hoy en día:
esto es, capacitar a los inmigrantes para postularse a cargos públicos
y dirigir un movimiento por la democracia inclusiva.
Pero no quiero que piensen que fue un juego de niños,
que EE.UU. me abrió los brazos y me dio la bienvenida.
Todavía no lo hace.
Y he aprendido algunas lecciones en el camino
que quería compartir con Uds.,
porque creo que juntos
podemos hacer que la democracia estadounidense
sea mejor y más fuerte.
Nací en India,
la mayor democracia del mundo,
y a los cuatro años,
mi familia se trasladó a Belice,
tal vez, la democracia más pequeña del mundo.
Y a los 17 años
me mudé a EE.UU.
la mayor democracia del mundo.
Vine porque quería estudiar literatura inglesa.
De niña, me sumergía en los libros,
y pensé, ¿por qué no ganarme la vida de adulta haciendo eso?
Pero tras graduarme en la universidad
y obtener un título de grado,
estuve yendo de un trabajo menos ideal a otro.
Tal vez fue el optimismo que tenía sobre EE.UU.
lo que me llevó un tiempo para entender
que las cosas no iban a cambiar.
La puerta que pensé que estaba abierta
estaba en realidad solo levemente entreabierta,
esta puerta de EE.UU.
se abriría más si uno tenía el nombre correcto,
el color de la piel correcto,
las redes adecuadas,
pero podría cerrarse de golpe en la cara
si uno tenía la religión equivocada,
el estatus migratorio equivocado,
el color de piel equivocado.
Y simplemente no podía aceptarlo.
Así que empecé una carrera como empresaria social,
en una organización para jóvenes como yo,
era joven en el momento en que empecé,
que trazó su patrimonio cultural en el subcontinente indio.
En ese trabajo, me convertí en defensora de asiáticos del sur y otros inmigrantes.
Presionaba a miembros del Congreso en cuestiones de política.
Me ofrecí el día de las elecciones para hacer encuestas a pie de urna.
Pero yo no podía votar y tampoco postularme para un cargo.
Así en el año 2000, cuando se anunció
que la tasa de solicitud de ciudadanía iba a ser más del doble
de USD 95 a USD 225,
decidí que era el momento de solicitarla antes de que ya no me lo pudiera permitir.
Rellené una larga solicitud
contestando preguntas sobre mis afiliaciones actuales y pasadas.
Y una vez presentada la solicitud,
me tenían que tomar las huellas dactilares,
algo para ser estudiado,
interminables horas de espera en la cola.
Se le puede llamar escrutinio extremo.
Y luego, en diciembre de 2000,
me uní a cientos de otros inmigrantes
en una sala en Brooklyn
donde garantizamos nuestra lealtad
a un país que habíamos considerado durante mucho tiempo el hogar.
Mi viaje de estudiante internacional a ciudadana estadounidense me tomó 16 años,
un tramo de tiempo corto, al compararlo con historias de otros inmigrantes.
Y poco después de haber llevado a cabo ese paso formal
para convertirme en estadounidense,
los ataques del 11-S de 2001
cambiaron el panorama de la inmigración en las siguientes décadas.
Mi ciudad, Nueva York,
estaba tambaleándose y recuperándose
y en medio de todo esto,
estábamos en un ciclo electoral.
Ocurrieron dos cosas
mientras tratábamos de lidiar con
la pérdida y la recuperación en Nueva York.
Los votantes eligieron a Michael Bloomberg alcalde de la ciudad de Nueva York.
También adoptamos por referéndum
la Oficina de Asuntos de Inmigración para la Ciudad de Nueva York.
Cinco meses después de esa elección,
el alcalde recién elegido
me nombró como primera Comisionada en Asuntos de Inmigración
para esta nueva oficina.
Quiero que volvamos a ese tiempo.
Yo era una joven inmigrante de Belice.
que había fracasado en varios puestos de trabajo en EE.UU.
antes de empezar una organización basada en la comunidad
en el sótano de una iglesia en Queens.
Los ataques del 11-S enviaron ondas de choque a mi comunidad.
Los miembros de mi familia, los jóvenes con quienes había trabajado,
estaban experimentando el acoso
en escuelas, lugares de trabajo y en aeropuertos.
Y ahora iba a defender sus preocupaciones
en el gobierno.
Ningún trabajo era más perfecto para mí.
Y dos cosas aprendí al convertirme en comisionada.
En primer lugar, los neoyorquinos bien intencionados
que estaban en el gobierno de la ciudad ocupando posiciones del gobierno
no tenían ni idea de lo asustados que estaban los inmigrantes
por la aplicación de la ley.
La mayoría de nosotros no sabe muy bien la diferencia
entre un sheriff, la policía local y el FBI.
Y la mayoría de nosotros, cuando vemos a alguien en uniforme
que pasa por los barrios
sentimos curiosidad, por no decir preocupación.
Así que si eres un padre indocumentado,
todos los días al decir adiós a tus hijos,
para enviarlos a la escuela e ir a trabajar,
no sabes cuáles son las posibilidades
de volver a verlos al final del día.
Debido a que una redada en tu lugar de trabajo
o un encuentro casual con la policía local,
podría cambiar el curso de tu vida para siempre.
Lo segundo que he aprendido es que cuando la gente como yo,
que entendía el miedo,
que había aprendido un nuevo idioma, que había navegado nuevos sistemas,
cuando la gente como nosotros estaba sentada en la mesa,
defendíamos las necesidades de nuestras comunidades
de una manera que nadie pudiera o quisiera hacerlo.
Comprendí lo que era la sensación de miedo.
La gente en mi familia lo experimentaba.
Los jóvenes con quienes había trabajado, eran acosados
no solo por sus compañeros,
sino también por sus profesores.
Mi marido, novio entonces,
se lo pensaba dos veces antes de ponerse una mochila o dejarse crecer la barba
ya que viajaba mucho.
Lo que aprendí en 2001 fue que mi voto importaba
pero que mi voz y punto de vista también importaban.
Y son estas tres cosas:
los votos, las voces y los puntos de vista de los inmigrantes,
lo que creo puede ayudar a hacer más fuerte nuestra democracia.
De hecho, tenemos el poder
para cambiar el resultado de las elecciones,
llevar nuevos temas al debate político
y cambiar la cara del liderazgo estatal, rancio e insulso
que tenemos hoy en nuestro país.
Pero ¿cómo hacemos eso?
Hablemos primero de los votos.
Lo que no será ninguna sorpresa para Uds.
es que la mayoría de los votantes en EE.UU. son blancos.
Pero tal vez le sorprenda saber
que uno de cada tres votantes son negros, latinos o asiáticos.
Pero aquí está el quid de la cuestión:
no solo importa quién puede votar, es importante quién vota.
Así en el año 2012 la mitad de los votantes latinos y asiáticos de EE.UU.
no votaron.
Y estos votos importan no solo en las elecciones presidenciales.
también son importantes en las elecciones locales y estatales.
En 2015, Lan Diep,
el hijo mayor de refugiados políticos de Vietnam
se presentó para un escaño del Consejo de la Ciudad de San José.
Él perdió esa elección por 13 votos.
Este año, sacó brillo a los zapatos de campaña
y volvió a presentarse para ese escaño
y esta vez ganó por 12 votos.
Cada uno de nuestros votos importan.
Y cuando personas como Lan están en la mesa política,
pueden marcar la diferencia.
Necesitamos esas voces.
Necesitamos esas voces
en parte porque el liderazgo estadounidense
no se parece a los residentes de EE.UU.
Hay más de 500 000 oficinas locales y estatales en EE.UU.
Menos del 2 % de ellas están en manos de los asiáticos o latinos de EE.UU.
los dos grupos mayoritarios de inmigrantes en nuestro país.
En la ciudad de Yakima, Washington,
donde el 49 % de la población es latina,
nunca hubo un latino en el ayuntamiento de la ciudad hasta este año.
Tres latinos recién elegidos se unieron al Ayuntamiento de Yakima en 2016.
Una de ellos es Carmen Méndez.
Ella es estudiante universitaria de primera generación.
Ella creció, en parte en Colima, México,
y en parte, en Yakima, Washington.
Ella es madre soltera, defensora de la comunidad.
Su voz en el Consejo de la Ciudad de Yakima
aboga en favor de la comunidad latina
y de todos los residentes de Yakima.
Y ella es un modelo a seguir para su hija
y otras latinas.
Pero el tercer recurso más desaprovechado en la democracia estadounidense
es el punto de vista que traen los inmigrantes.
Hemos luchado para estar aquí.
Hemos alcanzado oportunidades económicas y educativas.
Hemos alcanzado la libertad política y religiosa.
Hemos venido en búsqueda del amor.
Esa dedicación,
ese compromiso con EE.UU.
lo llevamos también al servicio público.
Personas como Athena Salman,
la semana pasada ganó las primarias
para un escaño en el parlamento del estado de Arizona.
El padre de Athena se crió en Cisjordania
y se trasladó a Chicago,
donde conoció a su madre.
Su madre es parte italiana,
parte mexicana y parte alemana.
Juntos se mudaron a Arizona y construyeron una vida.
Athena, cuando llegue a la cámara estatal,
va a luchar por cosas como la financiación de la educación
que ayudará a dar a familias como la suya una ventaja
para que puedan alcanzar la estabilidad financiera
que todos están buscando.
Los votos, voces y los puntos de vista de los inmigrantes
es en lo que todos debemos trabajar para incluir en la democracia estadounidense.
No es solo mi trabajo. Es también el suyo.
Y no va a ser fácil.
Nunca sabemos
lo que supondrá un nuevo factor en la ecuación.
Y es un poco aterrador.
Uds. tienen miedo a que yo les quite su lugar en la mesa,
y yo tengo miedo a no tener nunca un lugar en la mesa.
Y todos tememos perder
este país que conocemos y amamos.
Tengo miedo de que me lo quiten,
y Uds. tienen miedo a que yo se lo quite.
Ha sido un año de elecciones muy duras,
un recordatorio de que las personas con mi historia de inmigración
podrían ser eliminadas por el capricho de un líder.
Pero he luchado para estar en este país
y sigo haciéndolo cada día.
Así que mi optimismo nunca flaquea,
porque sé que hay millones de inmigrantes como yo,
ante mí, detrás de mí y a mi alrededor.
También es nuestro país.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)